[Applaudissements]
vous êtes déjà demandé à quoi vous
serviez
voilà je vous la corde la question est
volontairement provocatrice mais pour
autant elle est agressive et
certainement pas condescendante en fait
si je vous pose cette question c'est que
et quelques temps j'ai changé de vie
comme certains le disent je suis passé
d'un métier en col blanc à la défense
après de longues et aux études un métier
dans le secteur de l'art contemporain et
du secteur associatif en fait quelques
années avant ma sortie d'études j'avais
développé cette passion à ses dévorante
pour l'art contemporain en ce qu'il a de
d'actuels en ce qui l'a profondément
ancré dans la réalité pour recevoir de
sublimation et de dénonciation
par ailleurs javel intime conviction et
ça c'est certainement par orgueil mais
il fait qu'il fallait que je serve à
quelque chose
alors j'ai rejoint cette structure que
je cherchais mes enfants que je suivais
depuis assez longtemps qui s'appelle
take son insigne et qui combine elle
combine parfaitement art contemporain
engagement et solidarité donc cette
association elle a pour objectif de
mettre en lien le secteur associatif et
l'art contemporain par le biais de
projets ou d'événements comme des ventes
aux enchères caritatives ou des
expositions le plus souvent dans
l'espace public tous nos événements et
ton gratuit et accessible à tous alors
pour vous citer quelques exemples
on a par exemple
enfin notre pour notre première en fait
opérations en 2017 c'est une vente aux
enchères au profit de cinq associations
pour les personnes réfugiées qui a
permis de lever plus de 2 millions
d'euros qui ont été intégralement
reversés à cette association à côté de
cette vente aux enchères caritative
on avait une exposition au palais de
tokyo qui est un des plus grands lieux
en fait de l'art contemporain a parié
voir en france et cette exposition était
évidemment ouverte à tous après on a
aussi eu des pour des projets dans
l'espace public par exemple à l'occasion
de nuits blanches 2018 sur le pont
alexandre iii où il y avait donc
effectivement un parcours d'heure une
vaste collecte de livres d'objets d'art
on a récolté jusqu'à 35 milles et où il
ya eu un moment absolument magique où
vous voyez derrière - où la très grande
danseuse contemporaine marie claude
pietragalla est venu danser comme ça au
milieu du pont et c'était vraiment mon
fabuleux il ya trois semaines là on a
emmené cinq cents enfants dans les
galeries du viiie arrondissement de la
venue à matino des galeries d'art
contemporain mais aussi d'art moderne
vouloir faire comprendre que l'art est
accessible à tous qu'ils ont droit de
rentrer dans la galerie pour découvrir
l'art et voilà du coup la structure elle
combine donc du coup de type
d'engagement donc d'une part vis-à-vis
du de la promotion du travail des
artistes mais aussi vis-à-vis de ces
associations
ton vis-à-vis de ces associations
du coup je vais vous allez me dire tout
ça pour quoi en fait pourquoi l'art
contemporain me direz vous ou pas
d'ailleurs en fait je vous réponds tu
sais que pour moi l'art contemporain
c'est vraiment une passion parce que
effectivement il peut révéler des choses
il peut sublimer la réalité et il ya
vraiment un exercice de révélateur du
monde c'est en fait on le voit comme un
art qui est le fond serment élitiste qui
est foncièrement
presque mondain par moments alors que
pour autant en fait comme il est
profondément ancré dans la réalité il
est forcément
forcément compréhensible par tous à ce
sujet m j ai notamment une photographe
que je voudrais vous citez qui est une
photographe française qui s'appelle
sophie ristelhueber dont vous voyez
certaines photos derrière moi en fait je
me souviens quand les avaient découvert
que j'avais eu un véritable choc
esthétique j'avais découvert ses fins et
paysages qui sont très lunaire qui sont
très poétique et en fait quand je
m'étais renseigné sur le travail de cet
artiste
en fait j'ai j'avais appris que c'était
des photographies de guerre donc en fait
qu'il n'y avait absolument rien de
poétique dans ce que cet artiste essayer
de nous révéler pour autant
enfin pour autant c'est comme ça aussi
que j'ai compris c'est grâce à cet
artiste que j'ai aussi compris que
c'était là dans cet interstice là en
fait que se nichent l artiste pour nous
révéler des choses pour nous révéler le
monde en ce qu'il avait depuis qu'il a
de beaux mais aussi en ce qu'il a de
choses à améliorer
alors du coup
donc de fait
je pense qu'en fait ça t'arrive dois te
rendre rendu vraiment accessible à tous
et à ce sujet là en fait sens parce
qu'il a effectivement ce pouvoir de
révélateur en fait dans le monde et à ce
sujet là je vous citais en philosophe
que j'aime beaucoup qui est un
philosophe américain de la fin du 19e
siècle et du début du 20e siècle il
s'appelle john devine qui conférait à
l'art une dimension purement social une
faune une même avec une fonction
réconciliatrice en fait pour lui la
règle l'art la culture et créateur de
lien social
et en fait je suis particulièrement
d'accord avec john oui quand pour moi
l'art est présent dans l'espace public
d'ailleurs en fait ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que l'art contemporain
on a une image d'un art en fait qui est
extrêmement élitiste qui est extrêmement
mondain qui est cantonné à un cercle
restreint d'élus que seules deux très
petits c'est lui justement peuvent se
peuvent se permettre d'acheter alors
qu'en fait c'est aussi l'art le plus
exposé exposable dans l'espace public
par exemple en ce moment même
aujourd'hui vient d'ouvrir la foire
internationale d'art contemporain de
paris donc la fiac est justement tous
les ans depuis sa création en fait à la
fiac il ya ce qui s'appelle un programme
hors les murs c'est à dire que partout
dans paris dans l'espace public sont
installés des oeuvres d'art et je trouve
ça assez passionnante de savoir est
assez intéressant fait de savoir que le
public peut aller justement à l'encontre
pendant cette période donnée de l'art
contemporain sachant qu'il ya aussi des
oeuvres d'art qui sont présentes de
manière permanente et qui sont des
oeuvres d'art contemporaines dans
l'espace public en permanence
du coup je trouve ça assez dommage
finalement qu'il n'y a pas de cette
réconciliation en fait on entre le lien
social là cet espace public et que
finalement enfin il ya des commissaires
d'exposition qui font excellemment bien
leur travail qui arrive très bien à
expliquer mais je trouve ça dommage
qu'on ait cette distance finalement avec
l'art parce que pour moi il révèle le
monde et c'est grâce à lui en fait qu'on
peut réussir à savoir quelle est notre
place dans le jeu et revenir de fait
pour en revenir en fait ce que j'essaye
de vous dire c'est que donc l'art
contemporain il est souvent soutenus par
des mécènes et ses mécènes ils ont
souvent de très bon moyen donc l'âge et
c'était deux exemples derrière moi donc
il ya donc d'une part la vue là bas
d'une partie de la bourse du commerce en
fête qui a ouvert il ya quelques mois à
paris qui explose la collection de
françois pinault et à gauche vous avez
donc la fondation 8 qui est donc la
fondation de bernard arnault qui lui
aussi exposé à une partie de ses
collections d'art contemporain dans cet
espace et un pour autant et pour en
revenir à la structure avec laquelle je
travaille cinq sont infimes on n'a pas
du tout en fait les moyens de ces grands
mécènes on n'est pas du tout
milliardaire est pour autant on a réussi
jusqu'à présent et comme je vous le
disais à lever plus de 2.5 millions
d'euros
donc c'est que c'est en fait il est
vraiment ce qui me permet d'illustrer ce
que j'essaie de vous dire c'est que pour
moi l'art peut soulever des montagnes et
qu'on peut réussir à sauver de l'argent
sans forcément au départ être
milliardaire est d'ailleurs à ce sujet
là on a enfin deux autres projets à nos
prochains projets ça va être le projet
de la collective la collective c'est un
projet qu'on a remporté en 2020 sachant
qu'on est une toute petite association
on est on est quatre aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs à travailler à plein temps en
fait dans cette association et la
collection condom comme je le disais
c'est un appel à projets de la ville de
paris le plus grand appel à projets qui
étaient qui étaient enregistrés jusqu'à
présent pour réhabiliter la façade
d'enfer sur l'hôpital saint vincent de
paul qui est dans le 14e arrondissement
et je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
y sont déjà allés c'étaient les grands
voisins pendant un moment c'est un lieu
au plein d'acteurs étaient réunis
c'était très festif très très beau lieu
bref on va réhabiliter ce lieu est en
fait va donc on l'a nommé du coup la
collectif qui va ouvrir en 2024 et ce
sera un lieu où il y aura un musée il y
aura des résidences de jeunes artistes y
aura un parcours d'oeuvres en plein air
mais il y aura aussi des sièges
d'associations il y aura des lieux
d'accueil pour les bénéficiaires y aura
un incubateur sociale et solidaire alors
un restaurant solidaire également et en
fait ça va être un lieu où il y aura une
émulation collective d'où le nom vous
l'aurez compris et on en fait tous ces
acteurs vont pouvoir vont pouvoir
justement créer des synergies parce
qu'on pense justement que les synergies
peuvent être créés entre le seul secteur
associatif et le secteur artistique
du coup
du coup j'ai vraiment cet intime
conviction effectivement qu'il peut y
avoir c'est bien qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient faits justement entre ces deux
genres entre ces deux sphères parce que
même si effectivement comme je vous le
disais nous on n'a pas les moyens de
grands mécènes comme bernard arnault
françois pinault peut-être quelques
parmi vous se cachent quelques
milliardaires je ne le sais pas mais en
tout cas on a tous le pouvoir de pour le
pouvoir d'agir personnellement et si je
vous parle de l'art contemporain c'est
parce que c'est via ma passion pour
l'art contemporain que j'ai que j'ai
compris qui j'avais envie d'être en fait
dans ce que j'ai compris ce trait
réellement comment j'avais envie d'être
utile comment j'avais envie de dd que
j'ai découvert des artistes merveilleux
qui j'avais l'impression qu'ils parlent
le même langage que moi que il révélait
le monde en fait on ce qu'ils avaient
beau est ce qu il avait aussi de moins
bons en fait simplement par leurs
pratiques et de fait je pense que ce
sont effectivement deux chambres et
qu'on se réconcilier ou à rapprocher au
moins
donc tout ce que j'essaye de vous dire
c'est que j'ai effectivement il ya on
peut trouver cette utilité mais qu'en
fait il faut se mettre dans une posture
qui soit idéal justement pour comprendre
le monde en suscitant votre curiosité et
du coup si le l'art contemporain vous
l'aurez compris se base sur cette forme
de mécénat cette philanthropie justement
en fait ce que je vous dit en fait par
rapport à ça je vais citer qu'eux
d'ailleurs quelqu'un que vous connaissez
certainement qui s'appelle andré malraux
qui à dire en fait que l'art est le plus
court chemin de l'homme à l'homme en
fait cette citation moi je la comprends
comme l'a en fait qu'il ya un lien entre
nous tout ce qui a un lien entre notre
humanité qui est propre à chacun et je
la trouve vraiment parfaitement belle
mais je pense que je peux plus tôt vous
laisser vous imprégner de cette citation
et vous laisser la fin des rêves où
voulez vous laisser vous l'approprier
puisqu'elle doit être vraiment intégré
par marchand avec chacun d'entre nous de
fait pour en revenir à ce que je disais
on a tous notre place tous notre rôle à
jouer que effectivement il faut
comprendre c'est l'humanité qu'on a au
coeur de chacun d'entre nous
c'est pour ça que il ce même si on n'a
pas forcément les moyens comme je disais
de milliardaires de milliardaires pour
autant et là je vais en appelait en fait
à un autre un autre de mes amis
philosophes qui s'appelle marcel mouse
est en fait qui du début du 20e siècle
en fait marcel mauss il a théorisé ce
qu'on appelle le don et le contre-don le
don et le contre-don donc ça peut être
le mécénat donc en fait effectivement
des personnes dont je vous parlais
précédemment mais en fait ça peut aussi
être des dons adam d échelle beaucoup
plus réduite des seychelles qui vous
font comprendre justement que vous avez
votre place dans ce monde votre rôle à
jouer et votre place dans la société et
que vous en faites tout ce que vous
pouvez faire à votre échelle qui est
petit mais qui n'est certainement pas
négligeable en fait
vraiment vraiment est réellement une
importance pour en revenir à ce que
disait marcel mauss en fait donc il a
théorisé ce don et ce contre don d'après
la triple b obligations donner recevoir
rendre et en fait pour lui cette triple
obligation elle permet de générer en
fait du bien social est en fait elle est
fondatrice du contrat social est en fait
je suis complètement enfin vous l'aurez
compris sinon je ne citerai pas mais je
suis complètement d'accord avec lui
parce que pour moi ce à travers des
gestes des petits gestes en fait tous
les jours où justement on
on arrive en fait à trouver non
seulement un sens à ce qu'on fait mais
aussi à trouver notre place a trouvé ce
qu'on a envie de faire de notre vie et
avoir en fait on avoir mieux le monde à
voir comment est ce qu'on a
comment il peut être beau mais aussi
comment est ce qui peut être amélioré
de fait par exemple il ya un exemple
très simple s'il a tenu que je porte
aujourd'hui en fait elle est à l'image
un peu de ma garde-robe c'est à dire que
depuis quelques temps en fait j'essaye
de ne porter uniquement vraiment que du
secondaire donc celle ci c'est une robe
par exemple vintage que j'ai acheté il
ya quelques temps déjà et qui a été je
sais dans quelles circonstances a été
confectionné il ya 30 ans à peu près et
en fait en ayant ce genre de petits
gestes et en
en ayant une garde-robe enfin des
vêtements en fait qu'il soit exempt de
tout lien avec la fast fashion je me dis
qu'en fait j'économise des milliers de
litres d'eau un transport en fait depuis
des pays qui sont parfois très éloignés
et des conditions de travail qui sont
parfois assez déplorable pour ne pas
dire extrêmement condamnable
de fait ce que j'essaie de vous dire via
cet exemple qui peut paraître mineur
mais qui en fait que je porte sur moi
c'est qu'en fait vous avez tout votre
rôle à jouer en fait dans la société
mais en fait effectivement ce rôle que
vous allez trouvez vous n'allez le
trouvais que si vous mettez dans la
posture idéale pour comprendre le monde
pour vous en imprégner pour voir ce
qu'il a de beaux effectivement ce qui a
changé et il faut sans cesse que vous
suscitez votre curiosité ça peut passer
par l'art contemporain moi ça a été leur
contemporain ça vous ce sera peut-être
autre chose si je vous incite bien sûr a
effectivement aller voir des expositions
et à vous ouvrir sur le sur ce monde
merveilleux qu'est celui de l'art
contemporain mais voilà genre vous avez
effectivement tous votre rôle à jouer
donc et ça vous pouvez le faire mais
même si vous n'avez pas le pel de
bernard arnault vous n'avez pas
forcément l'histoire de la fondation
abbé pierre la force de frappe de
secours populaire ou même la fin
d'assurance vie de françois pinault
alors on fait ce que j'essaie de vous
dire c'est que j'exhorte je vous exhorte
chacun d'entre vous même si je ne
connais mais aucune des passion qui vous
anime ou des convictions qui vous habite
j'exhorte vraiment chacun d'entre vous a
trouvé votre humanité quel va être votre
lien à l'autre parce que en fait ce lien
que vous avez à l'autre et votre
humanité belle extrêmement précieuse
tant dans sa dimension individuelle que
collective et voilà pour moi c'est ça ma
vision du leap for challenge je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]